il ne fait plus bon de ne pas être
vaccinées en france hier soir plus de
900 mille personnes ont pris rendez-vous
pour obtenir leur première dose réaction
aux annonces des manuels mâcon le
président a confirmé que la vaccination
est désormais obligatoire pour les
soignants des hôpitaux ou encore pour le
personnel des ehpad le 15 septembre si
ces soignants ne sont pas vaccinés et
bien ils ne seront plus payés pour les
français qui n'ont pas encore obtenu
leur première 12 les portes des bars et
des restaurants leur seront fermées ces
retours sur la prise de parole du
président avec notre reporter david
khalifa près de 900 26000 rendez vous
ont été pris sur la plateforme d'octo
livre juste après l'allocution
d'emmanuel macro et hier soir un chiffre
non négligeable qui prouve l'impact a
des paroles elles d'emmanuel macro hier
soir pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que les
français n'ont plus le choix comme on
pouvait s y attendre l extension du
passani terre est bel et bien effective
et ce dès le 21 juillet à écouter dès le
21 juillet le pass sanitaire sera
étendue aux lieux de loisirs et de
culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents
ce pass est disponible sur l'application
tout senti qu vide mais chacun peut
utiliser la version papier remise au
moment de la vaccination à partir du
début du mois d'août le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux jeux si dans les avions trains
et cars pour les longs trajets là encore
seuls les vaccinés et les personnes
testées négatives pourront accéder à ce
lieu qu'il soit d'ailleurs clients
usagers ou salariés impasse annie terre
qui sera même nécessaire pour aller en
terrasse précision de gabriel attal et
un rétropédalage complet pour emmanuel
macron quand on se souvient de son
discours le 29 avril dernier cette
phrase assez évocatrice le pass
sanitaire ne sera jamais un droit
d'accès à qui
différent si elle est à français une
promesse non tenue et une stratégie
qualifié de la carotte et du bâton par
plusieurs ministres selon à nos
confrères du parisien autre mesure phare
et forme de désaveu de la part du chef
de l'état c'est la vaccination rendu
obligatoire pour tous les soignants sur
le même schéma que le pass annie terre
on se souvient du discours en décembre
2020 à des manuels macron avec un tweet
très évocateur disant que la vaccination
ne serait pas obligatoire faisant
référence aux pays de pasteur au pays et
des lumières est finalement un sept mois
plus tard la vaccination est rendue
obligatoire pour tous les soignants et
l'option généralisé est envisagée il
faudra tout de même que le projet de loi
qui est déposée aujourd'hui en conseil
d'état soit validée avant une
présentation conseil des ministres le 19
juillet prochain
vacciner les français quoi qu'il en
coûte voilà comment on pourrait résumer
la locution aide emmanuel macron hier
soir autre point abordé largement abordé
la reprise économique avec la réforme
des retraites projet loin d'être
enterrée puisque un texte pourrait
atterrir d'ici 2022
mais tant que la crise sanitaire ne sera
pas sous contrôle il n'en sera rien la
précision des manuels macron hier soir